Now that we've seen how
coordinates are related
between two inertial
frames, I want
to consider a slightly
more advanced example
for a moment, which is supposed
that capital V, the vector
velocity of frame S prime
relative to inertial frame S,
is not a constant.
So in this case, suppose
that frame S prime has
an acceleration, capital
A, relative to S.
We now say that as prime is a
non-inertial frame, because it
is accelerated relative
to frame S. Now
we saw that in inertial
frames, one always
measures the same acceleration
for the same object,
even though you'll measure
different velocities
in different
positions in general.
That's not going to true
in a non-inertial frame.
In a non-inertial frame,
the acceleration, A prime,
is equal to the acceleration
of frame S minus capital
A, the acceleration of frame S
prime relative to S. Remember,
capital A is 0 for S prime
being an inertial frame,
when capital V is a constant.
But if capital V
is not a constant,
then capital A is not 0.
So you will measure
different accelerations
in these different frames.
Now what that tells us is
that Newton's laws are going
to look a little different.
And let's see how that works.
So now, the force measured
in frame S prime-- I'll
call that F prime-- we expect
that from Newton's second law
to be the mass times the
acceleration A prime.
But that is the mass times
the acceleration measured
in frame S minus m capital A,
the acceleration of frame S
prime relative to frame S.
Now I can rewrite
this as two terms.
One I'll call F physical, which
represents the physical forces
acting on the object.
And the second term,
I'm going to call
F fictitious for reasons
that we'll see in a moment.
So what this means
is the following
is that an observer in
frame S prime in order
to explain the motion of the
object using Newton's laws
will have to invoke not just
the physical forces interacting
on the object, which
might be due to gravity
or rope pulling or
an engine pushing
or a hand acting on
something, but will also
have to both an apparent force,
which I'll call F fictitious,
that acts on everything.
And in this case, F fictitious
is equal to minus m capital A.
But that force will not
be associated, will not
be identifiable with any actual,
real physical interaction.
It's an artifact of the
choice of coordinate system.
non-inertial coordinate system
that frame S prime is in.
For that reason, we call
it a fictitious force.
And it's to be distinguished
from real, physical forces
of the type that we've been
talking about up until now.
So you may have
seen earlier that
for the motion of an object in a
circle around some center point
implies the presence of
an inward acceleration
toward the center of the circle.
So as a consequence of that,
a rotating reference frame,
for example, a
reference frame that
rotates with the
Earth's rotation,
is accelerated relative
to an inertial frame.
This results in a
fictitious force
that has two terms, a
centrifugal term and a Coriolis
term.
You may have come across
this Coriolis force
and centrifugal force before.
These are examples
of fictitious forces
because they arise from the
choice of coordinate system.
They're an artificial force.
They don't correspond to
actual, physical interactions,
but are an artifact of
the rotating, non-inertial
coordinate system.
Now, in this course we
will confine ourselves
to inertial reference frames.
And therefore, we'll
only be considering
real, physical forces
and interactions.
However, there are
advanced applications
where the use of a non-inertial
frame has certain advantages.
And you may encounter
those as you
go to more advanced courses.